we got four targets you're gonna do four  from the right four from the left first  one  [Music]  oh it hit that counts  we are one for one  bang  he's two for two on the top bottom one  oh  that one was right there  oh  all right miles we are three for four  moving to the left side  all right let's do this three for five  bang  we're going bottom target  money in the bank shorting what you  drank  five of seven  not only does he put a hole in it he  knocks it off it's bearing miles  robinson six for eight  six for eight on the header smashing  targets with force 64. and we want it  where 75 that's right he's not asking  for 80s he's not asking for that 75  that's right at least  you hear that  barely a heaviness to the breath  he's ready to go you ready to up some  more ratings yep let's go